[Music]
we're approaching the end of the second
speed run
probably will end around 23.50
and we've transitioned to 15-minute
games just because it is impossible to
talk about the games unless we have more
time
let's jump in
and we have the white pieces admin zhang
2010
all right admin zang let's play oh let's
play d4 i i think that
as we hit a higher level it
i think it's worthwhile to get in a
couple of d4 games
okay let's play you know we're gonna i
want to play because i i've never played
this in a speedrun game i want to play
the jabba london knight c3 and bishop f4
because i played oh never mind i guess
we're not playing tribal london
because black played e6 if we really
want to insist on the jebab london we
can play bishop f4 in this position the
problem is that black can respond with
bishop b4
okay we're gonna
we're gonna insist on it because of
course like we can play e4 but i assume
that our opponent is a french player
that's why he played e6 if you're a
french player like that's a huge
advantage because you can just avoid the
need to study the jabo or the varasaw
variation because you can just play e6
if you want
yeah so we're hoping that black goes d5
and transposes into the jaba
the reason bishop f4 is not considered
the best is because black can play the
move bishop f8 to b4 okay so d5
all right
now in this position there is basically
a fork in the road
the
kind of traditional way to play the
jebab of london is to put the knight on
b5 knight b5 in this position
knight b5
is not played in order to
try to win the pawn once he's like
obviously black has ways to defend it
after the game i will talk at length
about why knight b5 is played
but the move that i myself have played a
lot more with a lot more success is the
immediate e3
is the immediate e3 bishop d6
now we don't really need to respond to
this tension right we don't certainly
don't want to take on d6 a lot of you
guys probably are inclined to play
bishop g3
but in my experience allowing bishop
takes f4 is not that bad for white
why
because after we recapture with the pawn
those pawns on d4 and f4 resemble a
marotzi bind they clamp down on some key
central squares
uh it's honestly not not bad at all so
we can just continue developing
as if nothing is the matter we can go
either bishop d3 or we can go knight f3
either move is fine
i like the
i like going knight f3 here so a lot of
people at like 17 1800 level especially
they they just sort of automatically
play bishop g3 in these types of
positions but
if you're a london player you should
know that
allowing bishop f4 ef4 is rarely that
bad for white
okay bishop d3 continuing to develop and
we're hoping for c5
that's what almost everybody plays
against me in blitz is the move c7 c5
and then okay h6 h6 is kind of a waste
of time i think
so we should probably just continue our
development
no we have we have knight e5 here which
is kind of an interesting idea as well
uh 95 could actually be kind of annoying
for black
let me think
but i don't think we're in any hurry to
play it let's castle let's castle
let's castle c6
so black is playing this very very
solidly and quite passively
okay here there are a couple of options
the sort of principled way
to continue
is to play e4 but we can't play e4
immediately so if we want to play e4 we
should take trade bishops and then play
e4
and i think white is doing quite well
there the second option of course is to
put this knight on e5 if you've played
the london at all if you've seen the
line and you know that the knight often
belongs on e5 in these types of
positions
now the problem with putting the knight
on e5 is that eventually
that knight can be smoked out of e5 with
a timely knight b8 to d7 who can tell me
why knight e5 knight bd7 is a mistake
for black the immediate knight bd7 is a
tactical blunder who sees why
knight takes c6 or knight takes f7
exactly so after 95 the annoying move
that black has is queen d8 to c7 the
purpose of that move is to protect the
bishop and prepare knight b8 to d7 and
if we have to trade knights after that
happens then knight e5 essentially would
have failed
so after 95 queen c7 we have to see if
we have some sort of way that we can
support the knight on e5 one more time
and i actually think that we do have a
way to do that so we're going to play 95
and i'm fully expecting queen c7 here
now if you're a d4 player
uh there is sort of an idea that occurs
in many different openings
uh in many openings you put a knight on
e5 particularly in d4 openings
and that idea is known as the pillsbury
knight named after harry pillsbury who
was sort of the first to demonstrate uh
the potency of this setup and the
pillsbury knight is a knight on e5
that has nothing to do with the
pillsbury doughboy that is supported by
a pawn on d4
and a pawn on f4 so after queen c7
who can tell me
how we can set that up okay never mind
bishop takes e5 is obviously bad because
it gives away the bishop pair but the
way to do it after queen c7 would have
been to drop the bishop back to g3 and
then support the knight with f4 anyways
moving on bishop takes e5 is played now
most of you probably are inclined to
take back with the bishop but i would
not discount the potential power of
taking back with the pawn because that
is
a tempo gaining move and it chases the
knight away from its sort of natural
developing square which in turn allows
the white queen to make its way to g4
assembling quite the uh entourage of
minor pieces on the king's side so i
actually like d take c5
maybe even more than bishop takes c5
although bishop takes e5 is obviously
also very very good
but let's let's try to be adventurous
let's play de from a positional
standpoint this is a bad military it's
it's anti-positional to take back with a
pawn of course right because you're
taking a pawn away from the center
you're doubling your pawns you're making
your bishop worse
so you're making an investment right
you're sacrificing
positional drawbacks but you're gaining
attacking chances on the kingside let's
go queen g4 x-raying the king
threatening bishop takes h6 and we can
try to go for a quick checkmate here if
black is not careful we can try to go
for a checkmate here if black is not
careful in fact i think black is already
in pretty big trouble unless he defends
very accurately
i think black has only one accurate move
here which i to be honest kind of missed
but even if he plays it it's
still very very dubious for black
let's see if he finds the move
no i don't think it's king a trade i
think king h8 is what i was expecting
initially
but there is a move here that i
overlooked
which is f5 which is which is this
classic defensive idea to push the
f-pawn in such positions
increasing the blood flow
among black's pieces i don't know how
else to describe a move like f5
it's funny because i had a game in the
last tournament i played us open where i
had a similar type of arrangement and i
missed the exact same resource with f5
my opponent also didn't play it
now after f5 we have to take on passant
um we have to take on passant because if
we don't take on poisson after f5 our
light squared bishop is gonna be like
wtf
now i'm biting on granite
and the attack is gonna be a lot less
scary with that bishop no longer
controlling this key diagonal
so any sacrifice on h6 is going to be a
lot less effective subsequently
so our opponent is finally thinking
no i don't think h8 loses by force but i
think it allows us to
develop the attack very effectively
no the job is a very very dangerous
opening for black
we're only 10 moves in against the 2200
guy
and we're
you know complaining i'm complaining
that i'm not winning you know we're
definitely much much better here
yeah so after f5 queen g6 almost works
but after f5 queen g6 black has this
move queen to e8
offering the queen trade and thereby
preventing bishop takes h6
so after f5 will take on passant
and we're much much better there as well
okay f5
so we play on basalt
now our bishop remains active knight
takes f6 in such positions right you you
want to understand not only
like you want to have a an understanding
of what's going to happen in the short
term in the long run and one
effective way to
proceed in these types of positions is
to figure out what you want to avoid
like what is the worst case scenario
and that is going to help you
properly
uh continue find find good continuation
so what we want to avoid is black
pushing the e pawn up up to e5 we want
to avoid e5 because if black is able to
push e5 he opens the bishop he controls
the center and potentially the pawn is
going to reach e4 and shut down the
other bishop e5 is not the end of the
world but we want to try to avoid it if
we can
queen g3 runs into knight h5 you guys
are correct very nasty little move
and there you might notice that white
has queen g6 but if you keep calculating
after knight takes f4
queen h7 check is just one check the
king escapes to f7 and there's no
continuation to the attack so queen g3
is out of the way is out of the question
queen g6 again there is this move queen
e8 so after queen g6 queen e8
we could just make a a neutral move such
as bishop d6 offering a trade of queens
and getting an advantage in the end game
so that's one option
but preferably as you can understand i'd
prefer to keep the queens on the board
and i think the best way to keep the
queens on the board
is to slide the queen well if we play
queen h4 there's actually g5
which could be very annoying
because we can sack our bishop but i
don't think we have enough pieces for an
attack there
so what i think we need to do
this is not an easy move to make but i
think we should make it
is to retreat the queen of e2
it's to retreat that we need to
right it's okay right you
as tempting as it was to remain on the
king's side the queen was a liability if
it stayed on the king's side
now i'm hoping for knight bd7 which
would be a blunder but a very very
tempting move
the correct move for black i think is
queen e7
and we might not be able to prevent e5
we have to deal with that reality c5
okay c5 is a move that i didn't see
but i don't think it's very good
now first important thing to point out
here is that c4 is not a threat
c4 is not a threat because the bishop
has the g6 square which is actually a
completely safe escape square so what is
the drawback of the move c5 well the
drawback of the move c5 as is often the
case is that it weakens the b5 square
so that leads us to the tempting knight
b5
what does knight b5 do well it threatens
knight c7 but after knight b5
our minor pieces kind of lose some of
their support
nonetheless i think this is the best way
to try to punish black's play let's go
knight b5
the other positive thing about moving
the knight away from c3 and for you to
understand this uh let's go back to
first principles why is knight c3
considered to be inferior to the main
move who can tell me like why is it that
the varisov
had a very bad reputation until the
juvenile london came along and improved
it but still it's considered a second
rate opening why is that what is the
bottom logic well it's the fact that it
blocks the c pawn which means that the
d-pawn is now a lot weaker and you don't
have this c4 pawn lever that's so
important in d4 openings
so one of the good things about moving
the knight away from c3 is that you now
have the possibility to contest the
center with c2 c4
and that can really breathe a lot more
life into the position if you can play
c4 and really challenge black center
pawns
that uh makes all the magic happen
knight c6 okay
so what should we do now
who can tell me
i think i see a good move here i think
we can win material
most of you are probably tempted
with the move knight c7
but knight c7
runs into e5
you might look at that say well i don't
get it knight c75 i just take the rook
but don't stop calculating after knight
c7 e5 knight takes a8
black takes the bishop on f4 and then
knight on a8 is stranded black's gonna
trap it very very easily and get two
pieces for a rook so he might say okay
well let's go knight d6 but that knight
on d6 isn't actually doing anything it's
an illusion
not to mention that it runs into the
very same e5 trick
so should we go bishop c7 well that's
just a one-move threat the queen has
plenty of escape squares
but there is another move which is
bishop d6 and a lot of you guys named it
it attacks the rook it forks the rook
and the pawn but more important than
that it causes the rook a lot of trouble
the rook is almost trapped
if black
moves the rook to e8 the other bishop
can jump into g6 and then the rook
actually is strapped
so the only way for black to keep the
rook alive
is to slide it up to f7 so that it has
the d7 square in the event of bishop g6
but
in that case we can still play bishop g6
to force the rook onto d7 that rook on
d7 is going to completely
block
the
coordination among black's pieces it's
going to restrict the blood flow
and then in that resulting position who
can tell me what simple move white can
conclude the sequence with yeah bishop
takes c5 there bishop takes c5 there
exactly
yeah black could siri i would seriously
consider if i were black here to give up
the exchange but i don't know exactly
how black should do it
i don't know exactly how black should
give up the exchange probably black's
greatest
advantage in this position is is the
pawn center so one move that i would
consider for black and this is a very
advanced move this is not a move that
most
people like under 2300 would really
consider that's the move e5
c4 by our opponent
okay now we need oh that is a very good
move isn't it
okay actually this changes
quite a bit what i missed is that after
bishop g6 black has the move knight e7
black has the move knight e7
wow
that came out of nowhere
so that
leads us to
so we have several options here
we can play bishop takes c4 dc bishop
takes f8 queen takes f8 and queen takes
c4 we have a rook and two pawns for two
minor pieces probably a slight advantage
for white
also black's minor pieces are really
really poorly placed
we shouldn't take the rook because then
we only get one pawn for the two pieces
the other option is to play bishop g697
take that knight and then play a move
such as e3 e4
in order to try to break down black's
pawn center
i think both options lead to an
advantage for white
but
my intuition
it's actually very hard to say which
option is better
very hard to say which option is better
yeah probably bishop takes c4 probably
bishop c4 is better because this gives
us a solid material advantage
and it also opens up the d file which we
can use as an entry point
into black's position
okay bishop f8
and i completely missed c4 this is an
excellent move by black
this came out of nowhere
now as you can see at this level like
people regularly find stuff that i miss
of course i'm explaining all of my moves
and stuff so i'm more likely to blunder
but nonetheless big big props to
edmund zing
okay and queen takes c4
so now the game has entered a different
a secondary stage
black has a knight and a bishop
for
the rook
and we each have another pair of knights
okay so now let's play naturally and
let's play efficiently bringing the rook
into the game with rook 81
bringing the rook into the game with
rook 81
this move also potentially sets up
knight b5 into d6 which could be a very
very nasty square i mean it pressures b7
pressures the bishop
so we need to try to exploit to squeeze
as much
juice as possible from our superior
piece activity before black consolidates
and when i say that phrase consolidates
right what does it mean to consolidate
it basically means to bring the rest of
his pieces out and become a little bit
more active so bishop d7 rook d8
maybe chasing the knight away from b5 so
that gives us like two or three tempe
which we need to try to use
while black is still putting his clothes
on in the morning where should the
knight go
well we should probably go to d6 the
funny thing is after 96 black has this
very annoying move knight d5
96 95 cuts off the rook from the knight
and forces us to make a decision about
our knight
now in that situation we could trade on
c8 but i don't think that's necessarily
great to trade r knight for black's
bishop
on the other hand two knights might be
the worst
of the minor piece tandems two knights
are not
always that effective so let's go knight
t6 and after knight d5 will make a
decision
i have another idea
so i have a move that you guys are going
to like not like at first
your reaction to this move is going to
be one of like this looks very dangerous
to play
but i actually think this is an
ingenious idea
not e4 i thought about e4 but e4 queen
takes d6
e takes d5 e takes d5 rook takes d5 and
in that position black has the tactical
move bishop e6 i'll play them with queen
c5 maybe this is a blunder i don't know
why does this move not
occur to somebody naturally because
you're pinning your own knight right
you're creating a pin
but first of all remember that pins go
both ways
a pin is a discovered attack in disguise
but the second thing is that the knight
on d6 is actually not vulnerable at all
it cannot be attacked and the idea of
queen c5 is to push the pawn up to c4
eliminating
shooing away black's strongest piece if
we can get rid of the d5 knight if we
can control the d5 square we reopen the
d-file and that definitely benefits us
the other important thing about this is
that black still can't really develop
the bishop
because of knight takes b7
simultaneously defending the queen
nor can black play b6 that drops the
knight on c6 so it's just kind of hard
for black to make a move here
yeah
e4 is also possible c4 or e4 kind of do
this
do the same thing but
i like to keep the pawn on e3
because it controls d4 and f4 and those
squares can be important later on down
the line
yeah we're squeezing we're squeezing
we're squeezing black
and this is going to be a long process
we're not going to win this in the next
five moves
it's going to take us a while to
accumulate our pieces maybe we can
double on the d file later on
so as our opponent is thinking i'm
already putting together a list of
possible improving moves after
after we play c4 okay and our opponent
does the tr does it for us
so what is the purpose of knight c7 i
can sense that our opponent is cooking
something up
maybe he wants to play 98 but that's not
a dangerous move so
we we don't need to play c4 anymore
right that's fact number one the point
of c4 was to chase the knight away from
d5 our opponent has moved the knight
away anyway we don't need to waste our
time on c4
instead we should focus on something
more substantive that improves our
position a more tangible way
we have several moves that accomplish
that task
the classic idea is to double the rooks
on the d files the only open file makes
sense to double
make sense to double knight takes b7
doesn't work folks bishop takes b7 come
on calculate the other thing we can do
is
actually wait let me think about this
for a second yeah i think doubling rooks
here makes the most sense
no but sean pinto at the end of that
line there's knight e to d5 i'll show
this after the game no that line doesn't
work
yeah rook why not rook d3 because the
rook on d3 i think is a little bit more
vulnerable to potential knight attacks
like night before 95 again i'm not
talking immediately but later chess at
this level is often an interplay between
short-term considerations and long-term
considerations and a move could be good
in the short run
but bad in the long run you always have
to make that intuitive judgment call
so
people can sometimes struggle with this
knight b5
okay so that challenges the knight on d6
but
it doesn't actually impact what we do
i think
and there is a trap there is a vicious
trap that i'm cooking up here
i saw this trap when i played rook d2
so here's what i think might happen i
feel like our opponent might be enticed
by the possibility of taking this knight
and then developing the bishop to d7 now
the bishop cannot be captured because
the queen on c5 is pinned but that would
be a blunder due to what move who can
tell me
this is after knight takes d6 if black
plays bishop d7 immediately then that
hangs the b7 pawn
there's a classic idea remember i said
that pins go both ways this is a great
example of that knight takes d6 rook
takes d6 bishop d7 rook takes c6
and let's see if our opponent falls for
it
i think this is gonna work like a charm
although somebody of his caliber should
see it
he should not fall for this
especially because he's taking his time
yeah he should definitely see it there i
mean there's no way you know 2100 should
make this mistake but
what makes this harder to see is the
fact that bishop d7 is like a tactical
move right
it it
puts the bishop on pre so you're
investing your mental energy and making
sure that the bishop cannot be captured
that's a very common type of blunder a
move that has a tactical justification i
don't know if i'm explaining this
clearly and maybe you can relate to this
you make a move that is like quote
unquote cool or tricky there's a line
you calculate within that move that
justifies the move but you've already
expended the energy to make sure that
that move works and you forget to check
for other
annoying
you know other
possibilities queen c7 okay
what we need to figure out here is how
black is going to untangle if we can
keep black buried
we're going to win this game
so i see at least two possible
approaches
my guess is that black wants to play the
move e5 and open up the bishop so that
calls
to mind the move f to f4 to discourage
g5
but i actually think that we have a more
aggressive plan
and that plan takes its
inspiration from the fact that the queen
on c7 is now sorry the knight on c6 is
now pinned so you should come
immediately be generating an idea that
exploits
that fact and that idea is just to push
the queen side bonds b4 c4 and b5
b4 c4 and b5 let's go b4
let's go before rook d truck a lot of
you guys are enticed by but rook d maybe
even queen takes d8 rook t8 queen takes
the queen disease is what i call it when
you forget that your opponent can
actually give away a queen if it's for a
lot of different pieces after rook d
queen takes the black gets a rook into
miners for a queen and most importantly
all of the miners are defending each
other so i'm totally unconvinced by that
i think b4 is practically speaking a lot
more unpleasant for black yeah queen c7
knight c6 though okay queen b8
now i think we might already start
looking for wins
okay so i know probably a lot of you are
attracted by the possibility of rook d8
i don't actually think that is
convincing
what i think we should do is just
proceed with our plan i don't think that
we should we should change anything in
how we operate here
let me think about this for a second i
guess he wants queen a7
no but that doesn't work
yeah queen h5 is interesting
but then maybe black goes back to c7 no
i think this i think this makes a lot of
sense a4
why b4 instead of c4 yeah there was a
reason if we start with c4
black can actually play a5 okay so here
i think we have a tactic
here we have a tactic that liquidates
the game into an end game where we're
two pawns up who can spot this tactic
now the first thing most of you should
see is of course the possibility of
giving a check on d8
what we need to do is we need to
sort of
we need to mold that idea properly if
you start with
if you start with rook d8 check
then
let's calculate so rook d8 check right
knight takes d8
rook takes the eight check
king moves we trade queens and we take
the bishop we're chilling the problem is
that after rook d8 check black can
ignore the rook and play king h7
and after queen takes a7 knight takes a7
somehow black is still holding on
well instead we have a very ingenious
move
we can play rook takes c6 we can play
rook take c6 eliminate the knight
then we can take on a7 to distract the
rook and then we can go in and take on
c8
easy enough right straightforward
tactics
okay we can
i think it's more clinical to start with
rook d a check because king f7 is now
impossible
or maybe it is possible but
it's not to be recommended
yeah as i said of course we could take
on a7 first king f7 actually might be
black's best move nonetheless
black's best move nonetheless although
we're completely winning there in many
different ways
there's a vicious trap though that we
could fall into after king f7 because we
don't have luft so
when i look at a position like this
one of the most important things to do
is just to remember that you don't have
luft at the moment you don't have to do
anything about that but you should be
very careful about a move like rook d7
and there was a vicious trap after king
f7 that black could have set rook b7 i
saw this move
now we need to be very careful to
conserve as many pawns as possible what
should we do here
well what we shouldn't do is play rook
takes c6 because then black takes on b4
and there's actually a double attack
there's a made threat and the a4 pawn
hangs we should just play the move c3
defending the pawn i'm guessing black
will play a5 this is what i calculated
a5 is going to happen on the board
and then we take on c6
black takes twice on b4
we make luft
we make luft
and
very importantly the pawn on e6 is
hanging without that fact black would
actually recover all but one of the
pawns and have good drawing chances but
in reality this is a completely losing
end game
so we can play g3 we can play h3 it
really no not g4 that blows the pawn
come on careful careful careful careful
that blunders the pawn let's go g3
probably h3 was better but it again it
shouldn't matter this is completely
winning
and now
okay this is this is over just push a5
what makes this even worse for black is
the fact that the e5 pawn is also a
sitting duck so
it really doesn't even matter what we do
this is just so winning
yeah there's and there's a million ways
that we can win this we can put the rook
in front of the pawn with the rook a6
that's easy
if we want we can exchange
the
a pawn for the e pawn but
i want to play this as clinically as
possible
so what we're going to do
let me think about what i want to do
here
i'm trying to determine what the
simplest plan of action is
okay i think i figured it out folks
i'm going to show you a cool plan and
the only reason i do this is for
instructed value this is not necessarily
how i would play in a classical game i
think in a classical game i would give
up the apon for the e pun i would play
rook c5 rook d5 and rook d4 i'll show
you how i would win this in a classical
game
but
i think i have the possibility of
showing a
cool line here which is why
i'll choose this here
so
how are we going to proceed in this
position well first and foremost let's
make sure that we don't give black's
pawns
any
unnecessary
activity any unnecessary anything
i'm just going to go h4
what should we do now
no we shouldn't bring our king up just
yet first we need to make like the
typical moves here yeah rook a8
f3 is possible we don't need to push any
of our pawns we just don't need to do
any of that we go rook 8 a6 and a7
so we're going to get the situation
which i'm sure many of you have seen
before where you have the rook on a8 and
the pawn on a7
and the inherent
issue with that situation is that
if you move the rook
then you give up the pawn on a7 which is
bad so the goal in most positions like
this
is to engineer a situation such that you
can move the rook away with check if you
move the rook away with check the king
has to respond to the check and then we
promote the pawn this is when the pawn
appears on a7 so it could be on the next
move there's a bunch of different
tactical motifs that occur as a result
of the situation
if you're on the defending side you want
to avoid moving your king to the f-file
who can tell me what typical trick white
has if black's king lands on f7 with the
pawn on a7 again
yeah you play rook h8 you're like but
that blunders the pawn on a7 no because
the king and the rook are then aligned
and rook h7 wins the rook there's a
skewer so
if you have a pawn majority on the other
side of the board
the typical plan of victory is to create
a second passed pawn
that's anywhere to the left of the e
of the g and h file and then push that
pawn all the way up to f6 or e6 smoking
the black king out of its cage and
forcing it to land itself into a check
black resigns because this is completely
lost
that was a nice game
so i'll show a couple of demonstrations
after the game or after we finish the
opening
so we decided on age of london e6
of course again we can play the movie
for here i just assumed that our
opponent is a french player and i really
didn't want a knight c3 french
so if you're if you want to play java
london you you should be ready to play a
french from the white side you're not
going to face e6 often at all
98 of people play d5 here
but you have no it's not bad the knight
c3 french is the main line i just don't
play it
i play knight d2 in the french so this
would i'd be out of my league here
so after e6 bishop f4 i think
if you want to be annoying
you can try bishop b4
then white plays e3
and i recall analyzing this line knight
d5 and now knight ge2 and i'm pretty
sure that black can equalize here
pretty handily
and i see a bunch of
games in the database here
so knight takes f4 knight takes f4
you get a weird kind of position here
where
i think black is doing quite well black
is the two bishops and the possibility
of taking on c3 so something to analyze
here
so anyways black plays d5
all is good that ends well this
transposes back to the main line e3
now the traditional move here is knight
b5
and the point of knight b5 is to induce
the move knight a6
and the reason you want to induce knight
a6 is that knight on a6 is gonna have a
very hard time reentering society
now you play e3
and if black plays c6 a lot of people
kind of struggle with this idea like why
are you moving the knight from b5 and
back to c3 the whole point is that the
knight on a6 is now very poorly placed
and it can't rejoin the game easily
you can move it back to c7 but this is
not still not a very good square for the
knight this is passive
and now we get the bishop out to d3 and
sometimes you push e4 quickly
now you might say well wait a minute
black doesn't have to play knight a6
black can play bishop d6 but obviously
that gives away the bishop bear and here
white is solidly better your white is
solidly better you have the bishop bear
yeah so often in these lines what you
see is knight a63
c6 for example knight c3 and black has
made a million different moves here if
black develops like this
you can play bishop takes a6 yeah bishop
a6ba is a typical structure that occurs
in the juba i've had this structure a
million times now you give up the bishop
pair and you also give up the open b
file that can be used to pressure b2 i
personally am not a huge fan of taking
on asics in these types of positions but
largely it's a matter of taste
yeah my game against ortiz sawars was in
the juva london i actually had a
tournament where i beat two gm's in
classical chess in the same tournament
in the jabal london so i've been playing
it for a very long time
since before hans has been playing it
for the record
bishop d6
knight f3 i would put the bishop on d3
there
okay so castles
bishop d3
and again
bishop f4 ef4 is a structure that i kind
of like
for white because it gives us easy
access to the e5 square for the knight
and the way that black often fights the
d4 and f4 pawns is with the classic move
c7 c5
then we play dc and black plays queen c7
forking these two pawns
and after queen d2 you get this type of
position but i still think white has a
tiny pole here because this bishop is a
problem and it's going to be a problem
for a long time black is never going to
go e5
and white just has excellent control
over key central squares nice bishop on
d3 good piece coordination i would take
white here any day and i hope that makes
sense
engine would probably give equality but
practically speaking i think white's
comfortable here
so
our opponent plays h6 which i already
think is a step in the wrong direction
most people who have this position
against me play c5
and if you watch my blitz games you know
that i like to take on c5
then i like to castle and i have had
this position probably 50 times or so
not an exaggeration here i think white
is doing very well maybe you remember
some of my blitz games in this line i've
done some analysis here d4 there's this
move e5
and i think a lot of this has to do with
black's bishop being bad i think that's
a big reason why white is more
comfortable here
and a lot of people here
just sort of automatically trade
everything on e4 and hear why it is
solidly better
nice bishops
control of the d-file
black needs to be careful here in order
to preserve the balance
so i think white's slightly better here
anyways
you know we can talk about this for
hours
but let's skip the opening or let's
let's proceed to the middle game h6
castles and c6 very very passive very
passive
this just lets us do everything we want
to do sean pinto suggests g4 yeah g4 is
very interesting
not really i wanted to play more
positionally in this game so i didn't
even really consider but g4 here is
absolutely something i would consider in
like let's say a blitz game no g4 is
very interesting trying to use this pawn
as a hook and push this pawn to g5 you
know before black and finish
putting his clothes on in the morning
um no h6 is a very bad move it creates a
hook
it has no redeeming qualities to it it's
not like i'm threatening to go knight g5
here
right yeah g4 i think is actually a
completely legitimate idea even in a
classical game now i would be worried
what would i be worried with i don't
know i i think this is very good maybe
even the best move
no but if they take then you open the g
file
if they take you open the g file that's
the whole point of the move
black should probably take the bishop
here
because if you move the knight away then
you allow bishop takes h6
so you should take the bishop ef4
again you get this clamp on the e5
square
in this type of position give me white
any day of the week
queen f3 queen g3 just look at this this
is
this is a potential disaster for black
and if sean finza phenomenal suggestion
yeah but h5 is never a problem because
you can always just play h3 you know
it's like
that's always the
the rule in such position same with f5
f5 you just play h3
so
g4 would have been very interesting we
can check that with the engine after the
game but i decided to castle c6 and
knight e5
bishop takes c5
which is
honestly makes things even worse
to reiterate what i was talking about
during the game if sorry if knight bd7
for that matter of bishop d7 then we
play knight takes f7
attacking the queen and we win a pawn
and we get the bishop pair
so in order to prepare an ipd7 black
should play queen c7 and now i was
planning the move bishop g3
and after knight bd7 you establish the
pillsbury knight on e5 you have these
pawns on d4 and f4
and they support the knight and
pillsbury won
like a a thousand games
with this type of knight on e5 he would
basically play the same opening over and
over again he would get this knight on
e5 and he would just roll people off the
board he would completely roll people
off the port pillsbury was one of the
top
five players in the world in the late
1800s
unfortunately died very young but
you know he's that in his 20s but he
he contributed a great deal
you know to to chess and he was
definitely ahead of his time
yeah and in 18 he played a bunch of
games in like the late 1800s that just
like
people didn't know what to do with
you know that night on e5
okay so let me give you a very simple
example
so this is pillsbury against a guy named
uh james hannah moore
not a famous player by any by any
stretch but
you know probably a decent solid master
lasker did face and pillsbury did beat
lasker
with these types of lines so d45 oh
pillsbury literally would play the
stonewall f4
he was after morphe morphe i think
morphe died in like 1840 anyways
pillsbury lived a little bit after
morphe
pillsbury was cool and just look at this
knight on e5 ping the game is over
watch what he does
develops
i got it on ebay rook f3 it's called the
fifth american chess congress basically
the book is an overview of this
tournament strongest tournament ever
held in america
to date
he gives a summary of the opening dinner
and what's interesting is that they the
cake
for at the end of that dinner had a
chess puzzle
that was emblazoned on it and he gives
the puzzle
and it was funny that all the chess
players at the dinner were like nerding
out over the puzzle
and started competing over who could
solve it first
it took me it took me maybe a minute to
solve it it's a super interesting puzzle
all right let's look at the puzzle but
let's finish this game first so just to
show you to complete this incredibly
long-winded
um excursion
pillsbury just goes rook h3 c takes d4
white to play and win who can spot the
simple but totally devastating
sequence
and then i'll show the puzzle
yeah bishop h7 queen h5
and then he just destroys him bang bang
bang bang
pillsbury just totally murders him
knight h8 check
just takes all of his pieces
and it hit pillsbury one probably like
40 games like this just like this he
puts the 995 supports it with a pawn on
f4 lifts his rook up to h3 and
demolishes the guy
pillsbury knight
big big idea in d4 openings
okay now you want to see the puzzle let
me find it
white to play in checkmate in two moves
okay i have to resolve it i don't
remember the solution actually
so i'm solving it myself
okay i got it
i got it
oh it's beautiful
dude this actually look really nice
no i don't think it's queen b7
maybe we found an alternate no queen b7
queen b7
knight e4
queen b7 94 there's no mate
if queen b7 then then 94 and there's no
there's no mate
no it's it's rook d7 yeah rook d7
and whichever move black plays it's mate
if bishop f7 then rook d it is made if
king f7 e8 equals queen is made
if 9796 is mate and if
king d7 then queen c6 is made
if 94 rook d8
oh my god and if knight f8 holy smokes
ef equals night
ef equals queen is not mate you have to
make a knight
holy smokes beautiful
wow who was this dude did you compose
this in the 1800s
no queen eight is not made cause the f7
knight hangs
amazing puzzle
okay i can see why he was so obsessed
with this puzzle
okay
so
we were here 95 and we uh
clarified that after queen c7 my idea
was to go bishop g3
f4 and basically play this all up
hillsby bishop h4 and rook f3 rook g3
etc
but instead our opponent immediately
takes on e5 and in retrospect i probably
should have taken with
the bishop i think i should have taken
to the bishop maybe pawn takes was a
little bit overzealous
because honestly i was aiming for this
position and of course i missed f5
now if black had played king h8 here
this was my idea queen h3
this sets up the devastating threat of
bishop takes h6 now i think these people
would understand like computers
you can tell that they're like pretty
pretty modern like
it would be an illusion to say that
people from like the 1880s wouldn't
understand like you would be able to
explain that like there is a thing that
tells you what the best moves in any
position
they'd probably be mesmerized by that
for hours
they just want to like
test it
um
like the concept of a machine was
already very well known it would not be
too much of a reach
what are these beads you keep talking
about exactly um
in any case so f5 e takes f6 queen
knight takes f6 maybe queen takes f6
with stronger to prepare e5
but after knight f6 we play queen e2 we
retreat the queen
again queen g3 there was knight h5 queen
h3 walks into e5 so really e2 is the
only possible square for the queen
c5
now we exploit the drawback of this move
we put the knight on b5
we
invade with our bishop
and here i miss the c4 move i thought
that black has to move the rook and then
we basically went upon here with bishop
takes c5
after c4 i think we made a very good
decision to play bishop take c4 we
basically win a rook and two pawns for
two minor pieces
and this is a very very difficult
position for black mostly because this
bishop is in such bad shape and because
the d-file is hours for the taking so
the next moment that i wanted to point
out after rook 81
a6 96 knight t5 i think this is actually
a super important moment i think queen
c5 is the game-winning move
i think queen c5 is the game-winning
move um
because if we don't have queen c5 then
we have to move the knight
and if for example we trade black has
fully consolidated all of black's pieces
are now in the game it's anybody's game
a lot of you were suggesting e4 but here
after queen takes d6
e takes d5 e takes d5 rook takes d5
looks like white might be winning but
black simply has bishop e6
takes takes and maybe white i would
prefer white here but it's far from
clear
carvalma asks why not bishop g6 instead
of sacrificing
why not bishop g6 let's rewind ah why
not bishop g6 here because of knight c6
to e7
and my pieces are kind of stuck in mud
here you have to be very careful because
black is ready to play a6
and that's going to set up set out a
chain reaction where you're going to
have to give up the dark square bishop
to avoid losing a piece
so anyways back we go to
queen c5
and if you have to retreat the knight
then that gives black a chance to
develop the bishop and you've you know
the elephant that was sitting on black
is is gone
so queen c5 very important how did i
find the smell like what is the
underlying logic of this move there's
two things the first is that i realize
the knight on d6 is the the key to the
kingdom you want to keep this knight on
d6 at all costs because it is totally
destroying black's coordination
preventing bishop d7 once i told myself
i need to keep the knight on d5 queen c5
is literally the only way to defend the
knight so this speaks to the fact that
like very often if you can make that one
insight like oh i need to keep the piece
on this square or like i need to do x at
all costs it helps you figure out the
move because there's just no other
options
and a lot of it is about not letting the
sort of animal side of your brain
dictate
like everything about what you do
because like you have this side of your
brain that rules out a move like queen
c5 because it walks into a pin but once
you start probing
the actual nature of your concerns you
realize that it's a total
uh totally empty empty fear because the
knight on d6 cannot be attacked
okay knight c7
and now we decide to double rooks on the
d file rook d2 might be fibric fd1
and by the way all of this hinges on
this tactic if bishop d7 rook takes c6
wins the game if we didn't have rook
takes c6 the bishop would maneuver back
to e8 and black would slowly get his
pieces back into the game we would be
better but it wouldn't be winning
the fact that bishop d7 is impossible is
totally deadly black is losing here
what happens after knight takes b7 oh so
a lot of you were very enticed
by um
sorry by
the move knight takes b7 here it doesn't
work takes very unusual situation you
have three pieces on the seventh rank
but two of them can defend each other
and you might say oh i go e4 but the
third one can jump in to distract the
rook bishop c6 rook d6 attacking the
bishop but the knight drops back to e7
and black keeps the miners intact
we will check queen c5 with an engine
but i can bet you a silver dollar it's
the best move
yeah this is a nice line but also like
you shouldn't go for something like this
because simply keeping the tension is
just good on its own right
you don't want to take unnecessary risks
like that
uh so
knight b5 rook fd1 trade trade queen c7
and now another very important idea b4
c4 and b5 sensing that this is just a
totally devastating idea or b4a4 and c
and b5
a rook d a check a move that tons of
people would play very very bad move
because it allows queen takes d8
hopefully
it makes sense why this is not worth
going for now maybe white is still
better you could make the argument that
white's queen
is much more active than black's pieces
but black is gonna start consolidating
and minor pieces like when you have this
many pieces there's just a way of like
getting your pieces out
that white is gonna have to struggle
with like queen e7 knight c6
now you might say oh i'm just gonna go
queen e8 and i'm gonna pin this rook
forever but what are you going to win
with right you can't keep the queen here
forever because you don't have any other
pieces that you're going to win with
thank you henchman
so
this is a very instructive mistake rook
d h check and if you're like an
intermediate player you have to watch
that temptation and play these flashy
moves
and you want to make sure that the move
you play is independently good that
you're not just playing it because it
looks flashy
and the fact of the matter is even if
black plays king h7 rook d8 isn't all
that impressive
this is a much more substantive idea b4
a4 and b5 using your pawns
queen b8 is of course losing and we just
continue with our plan a4
now some of you were enticed by queen h5
which is a
nice move
preparing some sort of a mating net but
remember it gives the black queen the
possibility to re-enter the game
and yeah you have a check
but the king hides on h7 and i don't
think that white has a very clear
follow-up here
join the ranks
okay anyways queen b8 a4 queen a7 and
now the tactic rook takes c6 jeffrey
zhang is now a moderator
bc queen a7
and rook takes c8 now there was a
vicious trap here after rook d h king f7
i think we would have had to play queen
takes a7 and rook takes c8 anyway
because
ooh wait i just realized something no
this is actually complicated
so let me start by showing the trap
here we have the possibility of playing
queen f8 check king g6 and rook takes c8
this actually loses for white who can
tell me why
this is why it's so important to be
aware of what the flaws in your position
are if you're aware that there's a
problem with the back rank then black's
move becomes very easy to find because
you know this rook is vulnerable you
know that if a queen appears on d1 it's
mate so black is queen d7 and the game
is over white loses the rook because of
the mate threat this is how quickly
things can turn around
so instead of this if you want to go for
this line
then you should probably give a check on
h5 my guess is that this move is the
best continuation
and here the point is not so much to win
the bishop back quickly as it is
to just checkmate the black king
if g6 you just play queen h6 and the
king's days are numbered i mean this is
a made threat this is a threat
the king there's no way they can can
survive this
so that's what we would have done after
king f7 because the interesting thing
is that if you go to queen a7 rook takes
c this is actually really really bad for
white because black goes rook b7 c3 a5
same thing is in the game but
at the end of the line the e6 pawn is
protected by black's king
so white ends up losing the a4 pawn and
that's a draw
so king f7 is what i would have played
in a game if i were black i think king
f7 is a much better practical option
king h7 makes our job very easy and
again all of this hinges on the fact
that the e pawn is hanging if it wasn't
hanging black would take a4 and the
three on four would be a draw
okay so
let's fast forward to the end of the
game
where our opponent resigned and let's
briefly talk through
what the winning strategy would be in
this position so we're going to consider
two scenarios
the first scenario involves black
shuffling the king back and forth
so here the easiest winning approach is
to play e4 and then just to create a
password with a move f4 this is like
totally standard right totally standard
the fgf and you just push the pawn
and either black stroke will have to
move away from the a file or the king
will have to try to stop the pawn and
now you have the classic technique rook
h8 rook a7 rook h7
now more resilient of course is for
black to try the move e4
is for black to try the movie for now if
you want to be
super super flashy if you want to be
like
sexy
can anybody spot sort of a tactic i
don't know how to call this tactical
move it's a move that shows that you
fully understand how to win such
positions not f4
because f4 i don't have to take on
poisson you should play f3
f3
and if black takes on f3 you close your
eyes and push the f-bomb is restrained
and that's it the game is over
but black has a trickier defensive
option black can try to start checking
your rook a1 check
and you might look at this okay i can
just zigzag my way out of the checks but
not so fast if you start doing that you
run the risk of allowing black spawn to
promote
so who can tell me where should white's
king actually hide
in this
situation and without this escape square
f3 would be a terrible move
without this hiding square
the move f3 would be atrocious
h3 and the king runs to h3
bang
bang bang
ef e4
wait no i'm wrong this is losing
this is this is a draw oh my god you
shouldn't play f3 there's a beautiful
defensive resource black to play and
draw
black to play and draw rook a1
black has rook a1 there's a mate threat
on h1
holy smokes
there's a mate threat on h1 and if you
play king h2 black pushes f2
and you have no choice but to move the
rook away and give up a7 and this is a
draw so
believe it or not f3 actually is a draw
so in this situation we would have to
do things a little bit more slowly there
is a very simple work around you go king
g2
black has to stay put and now you play
the move g4 opening up a little bit more
real estate on the king's side
and what that does is it gives your king
more space
and once your king has more space now
you can play f3 now you can play f3
create the passer and then push e4 so f3
would be completely unnecessary i once
screwed up a game
precisely
in this exact way
so to conclude this analysis i'm going
to show you guys two games one of which
i won with a very similar plan to this
one one of which i screwed up
so
this position you can see the
similarities there's a pawn majority on
the king side and there's a pass to b
pawn how do you win this well we start
by playing rook b8 we push the pawn to
b7
then we use the past pawns on the king
side to create a passer but the passer
has to be on the f file
very common mistake for people is to
create the wrong kind of past pawn if
you create a pass g pawn or an h-bond
it's still a draw for example
for example so i played a g4 h4
g5
h5
f4 f5 and here you have to be careful if
you play g6
fgfg
it's a draw because black is not obliged
to take the pawn black and shuffle the
rook so instead i played f6
if king g6 then rook g8 is winning
after king h7 g6
if king takes down rock g8 if f takes
you create a pass stop unpromoted to f7
so
very very simple but you can see the
theme
in
in the works here
so now the game that i in this game has
such uh
a painful uh
memory attached to it because like i
played the sexiest opening in this game
what's funny about this is
this was the us chess league so to give
you a little history you guys have
probably heard of the pro chess league
right the pro chess league
the president of the pro chess league
was the u.s chess league and the u.s
chess league was basically the u.s
championship among cities you would play
online and i started as early as 2006.
you would play online and everybody
would meet in the same location all of
the city teams would meet you would have
to meet in the same location to play
your matches which built a lot of team
camaraderie and it was really really fun
i played for san francisco of course so
we would meet in the mechanics institute
and we would all play and i would always
play next to sam shanklin in the
you know anti-diluvian library computers
from like the 90s
so i played the sexiest opening in this
game we're playing arizona who was kind
of a rival of ours
and i was expected to win i have the
white pieces against the higher rated
guy
so i set this opening trap
94 94 knight g5
and that and queen f3
and i just destroy the guy in the
opening and sam shankland at this point
looks over at my board and he's like i'm
gonna take lessons from you because it
was such a cool opening
so eventually we go on and on and on i
win a million pawns i'm up two pawns in
the end game
coupons like this
the game is over right it's the same
exact end game we just looked at
so
we reached this position i'm still
thinking
how am i going to win this in the
easiest possible way well
all of a sudden i got a little bit
worried
the reason i got a little bit worried my
initial inclination was to play g4
but the problem with the move g4 is that
black takes it and goes g5 and all of a
sudden you can't create a past f pawn
you can't create a past f pawn well
valentinian king f3 where are you going
with the king
so i thought okay i'm going to go king
f1
and i came up with an idea i'm going to
go f4
king a2 rook b3
and now here's the idea that i came up
with f5 check
king h7
and again all of a sudden
i started getting really concerned my
initial idea was to play g4
and g4 of course is completely and
utterly winning
that is what i should have played
but what worried me about the move g4
was this crazy idea h4
g5
g6
and if white plays f6 there's the king
of stalemate and there's a renegade rook
situation
this is a ridiculous idea
so
of course there are ways to circumvent
this and the easiest way to win would be
to reach this position and basically get
the king to g5 and eliminate the pawn on
h4
how do you do that you can't go up to e3
but what you can do is go to the left
i mean black is in zugzwang you cannot
keep the rook on the third rank because
you have to keep the rook on the b file
then you go king e3 rook b4 king f3 just
make a waiting move every time black
cuts you off forcing the rook away again
and that's it the game is over you go to
g5 there's no stalemate black stalls the
g pawn you take on h4 and the rest is
very easy
so that would have been the way that
civilized people would have won the game
but instead i thought i came up with a
very sexy idea i played a move that
looks terrible h4
and my idea
was in this position to play the move g4
and if h takes g4 which i thought was
forced white pushes h5
i figured my king is going to stop the g
pawn so if g3 king f3
let's say rook b3 checking g2
and here
what is the winning move let's see if
you guys have taken the lesson away
from
what i just talked about what is the
classy winning move here for white h6
h6 forcing gh6 and now f6 and you know
the drill well you know the drill
but what i had failed to factor into
account is that black and start giving
me lateral checks and this is where i
was got terrified because
okay king e2 rook b2 checking through
rp3 check
the only way to escape the checks is to
go left
but once you go left the distance
between white's king and black's pawn
becomes very concerning g3 is now a
threat so i have to waste another tempo
bringing the king back to e2
suddenly black goes rook b5
and this is what i had missed
after h5 g3
white has to stop the pawn but that
gives the f-pawn away with check
i played h6 desperately
g2
you have to stop the pawn because hg
allows black to promote and black takes
the pawn with check moves back to b5 and
that's it it's a draw
it's just crazy how much
you know nuance can can be contained
these types of end games
so if you're on the defending side you
can generate resources in almost any
position
and
that ladies and gentlemen is how we will
conclude the analysis hopefully you
found
the end game instructive
the winning approach in such positions
is very simple you push the pawn to a7
to create enough pun
and uh
that's that bucko
thanks for hanging out hope you enjoyed
the games and
see y'all
tomorrow bye
[Music]